journée exceptionnelle pour 1600 enfants
les jeunes footballeurs âgés de 10 à 12
en plus jouer ce samedi 13 avril sur les
terrains d'entraînement de l'équipe de
france à clairefontaine
à l'occasion de la danone nations cup
leur coupe du monde a eu c'est une vraie
compétition qui existe donc depuis plus
de 20 ans elle et elle a été créée par
notre président après la coupe du monde
98 pour permettre aux enfants de
réaliser leur rêve le rêve étant de
pouvoir jouer comme les grands joueurs
de football sur des terrains connus
si certaines équipes sont venues
profiter du panorama d'autres au
contraire sont venus pour performer sur
la compétition c'est le cas de leur
strip voir où l évolution des gamins
après pour les gamins pouvoir se situer
par rapport à d'autres d'autres clubs et
notamment des clubs le plus prestigieux
que lui est un peu le astra par exemple
l'équipe de bus en cours est également
venu avec des joueurs sur les terrains
de clairefontaine même si les féminines
sont repartis avec quatre défaites en
quatre matches dans leurs valises
l'objectif de la journée est atteint
c'est exceptionnel ce qu'a déjà l'année
dernière en poète on n'est pas venu
c'est déjà bien d'être là qu'on perde
qu'on gagne au moins ces plaisirs jouer
à clairefontaine
un endroit qui est normalement réservé
uniquement à l'élite
toutes les équipes de france c'est une
expérience unique dont elles vont se
rappeler je pensais toute leur vie après
cette journée aucune équipe yvelinoise
n'est parvenue à se qualifier pour la
grande finale nationale qui se disputera
le 22 juin prochain à paris